your favorite football team is obviously
the Carolina Panthers and therefore
we're going to look at a game that I
played last year in Charlotte because
what am i doing next month going to
Charlotte see they knew at home you guys
are slower here okay and Charlotte is in
your favorite state what state is
Charlotte in hmm let's see everybody at
home is like you know on their computer
like what stage of Charlotte in now
nothing nobody knows I'll give you a
hint it's the home to the Carolina
Panthers yeah North Carolina that was we
call fifty-fifty guest good job yeah
right and the reason we have a good
reason why it's in North Carolina
nothing's in South Carolina so that was
the good reason the answer is never
South Carolina okay so I'm going to go
there to teach chess because I've
already taught all you guys we got to go
teach the people over there I actually
taught a school in South Carolina okay
that was scary
all right now this game was played last
year in the 2014 southeastern fidei
championship coincidentally last week
was the 2015 tournament and the guy that
I beat in the last round last year he
won the tournament this year but there
was a good reason you know what the
reason was
yeah because I wasn't there very good
good job all right somebody's paying
attention okay now this game was played
at around 3:00
I think against Edward Liu and I had the
black pieces and we did something this
scheme that none of you have ever done
we got all our minor pieces out and we
castled right wasn't it strange that's
what you should do every game okay so we
started out playing a sloth defense
that's called the sloth defense and in
this position grandmasters play three
different moves they play the move that
I played
they also play e6 which is called the
semi Slav and they played a six day and
actually I've played all of those moves
but not at the same time so I usually
play the slob
so I took notice that black is a pawn
ahead hooray
okay and if I get a chance I'm going to
defend my pawn and I'll be a pawn ahead
forever but he didn't let me do that
because he's mean he played a four now
if I do that he just starts taking me
now he wants to play in the center with
efore but I didn't let him do that
no I'm kidding I did so I couldn't play
Bishop f5 that's what I usually do but
this game I played east six and he
played III attacking my pawn and I can't
really defend it so I played c5 and we
traded a lot of pawns and we got our
pieces out okay now in this position
White has three pieces out and Black has
three pieces out White Castle to black
Castle yet now boo also White's Bishop
has lots and lots of squares to go to my
bishop doesn't have very many okay so
white has those two advantages White's
Bishop has a lot of squares of mine
doesn't and White Castle but I didn't
however white has a disadvantage if you
look at the pawn structure my pawns are
all together right they're all next to
each other is that pawn next to one of
his pawns and what do we call that you
an isolated pawn I'm going to go take
that pawn later I'll try to okay so he
got his last piece out and I castled and
he put his rook in the middle now I got
to figure out what to do with this guy
now when I watch you guys play you guys
move the same night every move until
your arm hurts then you move some other
piece okay
but when masters play we move all of our
pieces so like this guy he moved all of
his minor pieces and he castled
I moved most
my minor pieces and I castled but I
still didn't move my bishop normally I
would play b6 and put my bishop on b7
but I was afraid because my Knights not
defended so instead I played Bishop d7
and I still want my Bishop on this
diagonal it's just I did it a different
way and my opponent played Queen e2 and
now how do I put my bishop on this
diagonal did I take my own Knight
why not right but what if I could that
would be good right okay so I did what
you said
because I predicted you would say that a
year ago yeah
now in some of these positions but not
this one this pawns on a2 and my
opponent could play a3 and I can't do
that
but his pawns on a4 so my knight can go
here forever his he can never attack my
knight this pawn is gone and this pawns
all the way up here so that Knight can
sit there forever and he can do he can't
go to those squares because I'll take
him what a great night okay so he played
a rook to d1 his rooks are in the middle
and I played like you said Bishop c6 now
my bishops really good hooray also all
my pieces are pretty good okay so if you
have a chess computer at home a chess
engine and you put this position in
it'll say it's about equal okay and then
whoever plays better will win hopefully
okay unless my opponent plays better
then hopefully he'll blunder okay then
my opponent played 95 because he wants
to come get me and I played Knight to d5
because if we trade all the pieces he
won't come get me and in this position
White's pieces are more active how do we
know well let's pretend this is the
middle of the board because that's the
middle of the board and if we look at
the middle of the board the fourth in
the fifth row my opponent has three
pieces and I have one so my opponent is
crushing me and I'm too
ding okay right but if we trade all the
pieces off how's you going to crush me
with no pieces so I played nine to g5
now all the pieces can take each other
okay like these pieces can take each
other these pieces can take each other
this can take this this can take this
this is protected twice this is
protected so many times I can't even
count that I
I think it's protected four times yeah
so we're going to start trading all the
pieces off and then he won't be able to
attack me
because he'll have no pieces okay and
that's what happened he took my bishop
I took his bishop and he said I don't
want to trade pieces and he played b3 b3
doesn't really do anything but it text
this pawn which was already protected
but now it's protected more yeah right
and I played rook in the middle and he
played knight in the middle and I played
Bishop back to safety eventually he'll
take my bishop but not now
and he played Knight here so now once
again he has three pieces in the middle
and I have two which is more than one
but I still want to trade pieces so he
doesn't crush me and I played knight c6
and I said hey let's trade pieces and he
said now we're not going to trade pieces
and in fact his move trades all the
pieces so that was good for me so I took
his knight he took my knight
I took his bishop and he took my bishop
now one of the reasons I'm showing this
game other than the fact that I'm going
to Charlotte and this game was played in
Charlotte and Charlotte's 14 and now
they're playing Atlanta right now
although as far as you know they played
on lanta three or four days ago the main
reason I'm showing this game is because
of the name of this class chess for
Knights and we each got a knight okay
and one of the Knights is getting
attacked and one of the Knights is doing
the attacking okay now normally when I
teach chess to beginners if they see
doubled pawns they start crying they're
like I don't like
blondes okay double pawns and we're puns
are lined up on the same line and they
don't like that okay and that's true
double pawns
sometimes aren't very good okay and
again my pawn structure is perfect my
pawns are all next to each other his
pawns not not as much now let's go back
half a move so I can show you a trick
because tricks are for kids in this
position remember my opponent took with
a pawn some of you were thinking hmm why
didn't he take with a queen now his
pawns are perfect what's wrong with that
guy why did he take with a pawn and
actually there's an answer and if you
know about chess for Knights you'll
figure it out chess for Knights
for Knights you I could retreat my
knight to c7 then then his Queen would
take my pawn and I would cry it yeah but
he move his Queen take my pawn and I cry
then he takes back oh then I went his
Knight
the guy's got a point so after nine c7
he would have to defend his knight then
if I take his rook he takes my rock or
we could play like me and lose a night
for nothing which is good because this
is chess for Knights
okay so nice c7 is a good move but I
played even better but you're 2/3
correct that's a very high percentage
we're going to find out in a second
Knight to see here you said 9 to c7
that's 2/3 correct ok so 9 to c3 and
that's called a spoon I mean a knife I
mean chopsticks wait what's that called
a fork a skewer
wait let's listen let's listen to you
what do you say he's the closest to the
board so he's right Shh who's the
quietest now some of you are confused
some of you because the rook can take
the knight
ok but the only free night around here
is at the Chase Park Plaza that's the
only free night I
now rook takes rook and white is in
trouble
half of you think it's checkmate half of
half of them but Queen here and whites
doing great now whites whites doing
terrible ok so my opponent didn't want
that to happen so he took with a pawn
and when he takes to the pawn if I play
Knight c3 again now his Queens
protecting his rug because his Queens
not on b5 over here so did I play Knight
c3 giving my knight away I should have
because it's chess for Knights but I
didn't know about this class then this
class didn't exist then it's called
something else
so I played Knight f4 attacking his
queen and he didn't want me to take his
queen so he moved his queen
ok and he played Queen e3 but he had a
good reason to play queen e3 because his
rook is overworked it's defending his
night and it's defending his rook so he
was like man if the guy takes my rook
then he'll take my night so he defended
his knight again
now his Knights defended twice okay now
the game gets really tricky and
complicated which is good because the
name of this class is chess for tricky
and complicated oh wait no it's not
probably next year right we got to have
a new name for the class okay so now I
wasn't sure how I should win I was like
this guy has messed up pawns although I
like checkmating his King too
what a tough decision should I check
meet him or take upon that's something
the class I take apart right so I was
like why can't I do both okay
professional athletes always wanting
more okay so I played rukka check I
can't believe he found the best move can
you believe it
okay how many legal moves does white
have how many possible moves incorrect
you with the right answer - he can take
rook takes rook
can play Queenie one also good now
Queenie ones terrible so he played rook
takes rook okay
now legal not illegal now you gotta get
the wax out of your ears
hi now I played rug to DA and he made
the losing move now I like rook to d8
because this is attacked and this is
attacked and this is attacked and this
is attacked that causes the most
confusion now some of you are confused
because you're like wait a minute
he takes your Rock and he takes your
knight why'd you give your night away
why did I give my night away because I
want to check meet him and st. Louis
even though it's in Charlotte okay and
so he was like wait a minute that's
check for me I don't like that so what
he should do well he should do that
except not take my knight so instead he
made the losing move because it was too
complicated for him he played rook c1 or
he went backwards how do you go
backwards okay play a trick c1 BAM
and I think the best move is rook a1 and
I think rook takes rook is the second
best move
I haven't analyzed this game in a year
he thought that was the safest move he
was like I'm defending my knight I'm
defending my knight again I'm stopping
checkmate with my rock and I'm
threatening his knight he thought he had
everything he thought he was all set now
when you watch a grandmaster game
between two grandmasters usually it
looks really boring they trade all the
pieces and they agree to withdraw and
then everybody falls asleep for example
in the Qatar Open which is taking place
now on the top nine boards there were
eight draws and one person one and the
person who won he gets to play Carlsen
tomorrow that'll show him teach him to
win day gets a tough hearing okay so
those guys it looks like this they trade
all the pieces and they draw okay but
this guy wasn't a grandmaster so he made
a bad move
of he thought he was playing safe but
actually he whined his pieces up where
they could get in trouble we have a
piece over there and a piece over there
it's hard to fork them it's hard to
attack them both but if they're lined up
up and down sideways or diagonal now you
can fork those pieces okay and so when
he played rook c1 notice how he lined up
his pieces on the diagonal also he did
something you should never do in chess
or in real life he walked into a fork
that hurts
okay that's why we're in this room if
you were in that we'd be walking in the
forks all the time okay lots of works in
that room and if my knight goes to e2
that would fork his king and rook but if
he played rook to a1 there's no way my
knights going to fork his king and rook
so Rick c1 was the losing move how did I
punish my opponent on the diagonal how
can I put a diagonal piece on the
diagonal you with the right answer
no that's right that is right he doesn't
know you're not on the answer you said
you didn't know so you're right you with
the right answer Queens g5 now my Queens
lined up with his queen and rook but I
have a more important threat a threat
only you can see yeah that's the
complicated threat not a simple threat
that's half right you would be really
right answer
right queen g2 checkmate with advantage
right and this is the two o'clock class
so somebody sure got that not just you
like most of the class okay
now my opponent didn't want to get
checkmated because then I win if he
plays queen g3 that would show him who
the boss is
not him that he loses all of his pieces
man I win so many pieces I'm confused
okay so he didn't do that right so now
the computer says no laughing the
computer says the best move for white is
Queen takes Knight that's the best okay
that means his games not very good so
the computers like man now White's
losing a queen terrible if you're at
home put this on your computer I'll say
plus a trillion okay it really likes
blacks position okay now let's say you
don't want to give up your queen but you
still want to stop checkmate what do you
do but you don't want to give your queen
away g3 okay my opponent what did he do
okay he resigned he gave up he did okay
let's pretend he played g3 now you are
you somebody you I think gave the right
answer what is black do here 92 check
that's an x-ray a fork and a skewer plus
tax yeah
what's an x-ray that's when you attack
or defend a piece through another piece
that's an x-ray so my queen is attacking
his rook through his queen
because if his queen takes my knight now
I take all of his pieces Queen takes
rook check and Queen takes Knight where
all his pieces go on the side of the
board where my comer likes to look okay
right now if he moves his King because
he's in check so that would be a way I
check then I could trade Queens and then
a free ruck so either way I'm up a rock
now he could also protect checkmate he
doesn't have to play g3 he could play
Queen f3 that protects checkmate now
what would I do
he stopped check me there's like five
good answers you that was what I would
do but other like Knight g2 is Knight
age three wins yeah okay but I'm not
saying I would I would play 92 yeah
92 check Dom yum yum yum yum and now do
I play rugby one winning his Queen and
checkmating him or Queen takes Knight
with an extra ruck okay that's not
really a Sophie's Choice there all right
so he was like hey g3 loses Queen g3
loses Queen f3 loses Oh because now he
realized 92 check and he walked into 92
check because he played rook c1 if his
rook was on some other square like a1 I
don't have any of those tricks you work
c1 the only bad move what is that game
teach you did you do something important
when you're playing chess and you lose
or you win it doesn't mean let's say you
lost it doesn't mean you played all bad
moves and your opponent played all good
moves it's possible but more likely the
position was about equal like this one
then the guy makes one really bad move
like that like that one Rick c1 and then
after this he's like oh no rook c1 can I
take that back you know Preston so
several years ago one of our chess club
members was playing in a tournament
against another chess club member and he
made a move and he hit the timer and
then he was like oh no and he said can I
take that move back what was the answer
now that was Preston versus Matt Larson
yeah you can guess who did what to whom
yeah you have to edit out all your
laughing right so when you make a bad
move in chess and then you let go you
can't say oh no that was terrible at -
too late
so instead you should look nonchalant
when you blunder all your pieces just
look confident like I play great if
you're like oh no your opponent will see
what you did wrong because of the back
rank issues of checked me because of his
rook hanging because of the fork and
because of the checkmate
he gave up this Knight was doing nothing
that night was silly now if we go back
if he played rook a1 a better move you
made me take my pawn later who knows and
I threatened check me and he stops
checking me I can't be forking his king
and rook because there's no ruck there
so if I check he just take me in lie off
so the losing move was rook C one that
walked into a forked and it walked into
an x-ray ok and actually that happened
to me last month of the doctor they did
an x-ray they found a fork inside okay
and I thought it was because I ate too
quickly but it was actually a knight a
king and rook inside me I was hungry so
I ate them and they made a fork right
yeah that kid agrees I now after that
chest 4/9 with all my great Knight moves
now you can play each other but make
sure you do a lot of knife Forks